a lot of the hate and the perpetuation
comes from like oh you stole him Haley
Bieber isn't holding back addressing the
claims she stole her now husband Justin
Bieber from Selena Gomez it's about
people knowing the truth because there's
a truth the model appears on the call
her daddy podcast and in a teaser clip
that dropped ahead of the Wednesday
release for the first time ever Haley
talks about the drama surrounding the
start of her relationship with Justin
how has being married to someone with
that level of Fame impacted your
identity
where do I start yeah and that Fame came
with the idea that Haley stole Justin
from Selena oh my goodness why because
in 2018 the Grammy winner proposed to
Haley just months after splitting from
cell whom he dated on and off for years
your husband
was in a very public relationship people
were obsessed with them being together
were you ever with Justin romantically
at the same time as her this is so crazy
I've literally never talked about this
ever
a lot of the hate and the perpetuation
comes from like oh you stole him
it's about people knowing the truth
because there's a truth he's just really
sweet he's a good kid he's a good part
and uh I love him and get this some fans
are honing in on the timing of Haley's
interview thinking the model's doing a
bit of early damage control Haley's chat
drops one week after cell debuted the
trailer for her documentary my mind and
me a project six years in the making
that covers the ups and downs of
Selena's personal life
[Music]
but this isn't the first time the ladies
have been pitted against each other I
would love to have the opportunity to
sit down with every single person who
has ever said anything mean to me
because
that would be helpful
back in May it was Selena offering an
apology to Haley after both ladies
dropped Beauty tutorials and cell was
accused of mocking the model in hers
just gotta get that glow in the skin
a screenshot from a fan account shows an
alleged comment from Selena reading this
is why I believe in taking care of your
mental health guys no idea what I did
but I really am sorry zero bad intention
deleting soon and that controversy came
shortly after Haley's emotional plea to
be left alone on social media leave me
alone please enough time has gone by
where it's valid to leave me alone I beg
of you truly
that's my only request
miserable somewhere else please to get
the whole truth behind all the drama
fans will just have to wait until
Haley's fool call her daddy podcast when
it drops Wednesday on Spotify where do I
start
[Music]